الحكم الصادر من المحكمة
قاضية باريس هو الحكم الذي
من المدهش جدا انه جدا
عجيب لأنها تفتقد كل شيء
عنصر مادي لأي دليل على أي
العنصر الطبي الذي تقرر
تفضل قصة كلمة بالأحرى
كان هناك شخص آخر في
غرفة ماريوت تلك الليلة الثانية
يروي الناس قصتين
واحد مختلف يروي قصة
من اغتصاب الآخر يحكي قصة
من مشادة بين
اثنان تحتاج إلى دليل مادي
لتأسيس واحدة أو أخرى من السرد
لتقرير ما إذا كان هذا هو
لذلك الحق في الحكم
اختيار تصديق الضحية و
تعتزم تصديق فقط
ضحية الحكم من الواضح
مشكوك فيه وتجاهل للمبادئ
من افتراض البراءة
الخبرة الطبية التي تم القيام بها
أظهر أنه السابق لا يغيب
أثر الحمض النووي في الأعضاء التناسلية
صلى لهم ما يدل على
الدليل على عدم وجود فعل
اغتصاب قد يكون سعد قد ارتكبه
lamjarred وعلى الرغم من هذا
عنصر هو على الرغم من هذا الدليل
الطبية التي قررت المحكمة منحها
سبب للسيدة لورا بريول ماذا
من الواضح أننا نعتبر
مروع للغاية وغير عادل للغاية
ولماذا نعود اليوم
هاجم سعد المجرد مرة أخرى بعد ذلك
لماذا الكثير منذ الحقائق لأن
أن العدالة بطيئة في فرنسا لأن
أن العدالة تأخذ وقتها في فرنسا
لأن سيدتي بريول قررت
اجعل هذا الإجراء يدوم
لوقت طويل برفضه عندما كان
إرادة القضاة أن نذهب
في المحكمة ما كان يمكن أن تفعله
قرار صدر في عام 2019 بدلاً من
أمام محكمة الجنايات وهو أ
تشكيل جنائي واسع ومن
الإعداد هو أكثر من ذلك بكثير
طويل
لذلك هناك ما عنده سعد
lamjarred لإجراء مكالمة على ما أعتقد
لديهم أيام من أيام المحاكمة
إجراء مكالمة ولكن ماذا تفعل
تغيير عند إجراء مكالمة
من الناحية القانونية
لدينا بالفعل عشرة أيام
التفكير لأيام لتحليل
قرار المحكمة وصيتي وذاك
نواصل القتال وأننا
اذهب إلى محكمة الاستئناف والمحكمة
يمكن أن تقرر المكالمة كل ما يقال
التي قد تقررها محكمة الاستئناف
لإلغاء الحكم الذي تم إصداره و
لتقديم قرار آخر يجعله
البراءة انها دي lamjarred ولك
لاحظ كيف ستنتهي
بعون ​​الله نؤمن بذلك
عندما يكون هناك قصتان من
الشخص المتهم والذي
تسود وعند أي افتراض
الحقيقة إذا كان يجب على الحقيقة القضائية
أن تكون الحقيقة العلمية ثم الحقيقة
lamjarred بريء من الاغتصاب الذي نقوم به
الذي يلقي باللوم عليه في عمولته